i'm stuart varney i'm martha mccallum
i'm jason chaffetz and this is the fox
news rundown
wednesday may 25th 2022 i'm lisa brady
the horrific attack on an elementary
school in south texas raises familiar
questions about school security we can't
be protecting
all the time from these these creatures
that that can loom from the swamp and
commit these horrendous acts so i think
what we need to be looking at is
hardening the the school perimeters
i'm dave anthony a feared new surge of
migrants to the border is still on hold
with a judge still preventing the biden
administration from lifting a trump-era
policy blocking some from entering the
u.s but many keep coming anyway it's
worse this year than it was last year
the numbers are significantly up
compared to last year and last year set
the all-time record so
when fiscal year 2022 is done we could
be pushing upwards of well over 2
million illegal crossings
and i'm guy benson i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
the unthinkable has happened again a
gunman opening fire in an elementary
school killing at least 18 children and
a teacher in uvalde texas west of san
antonio robb elementary is home to
second third and fourth graders meaning
around ages seven to nine
hal harrell is the school superintendent
my heart was broken today
for a small community
and we need your prayers to get us
through this the texas department of
public safety says the suspect was 18
years old salvador ramos believed to
have shot his own grandmother before
going to the school he was killed in a
shootout with responding
officers hoped
when i became president i would not have
to do this
again
another massacre president biden was
briefed about the shooting on his way
back from asia and spoke after arriving
back at the white house calling for
turning pain into action by as he puts
it standing up to the gun lobby why are
we willing to live with this carnage
why don't we keep letting this happen
where in god's name is our backbone he
ordered flags to fly at half-staff
through saturday at the white house
federal buildings and military posts
what are we doing
why are you here connecticut democratic
senator chris murphy appealing to fellow
lawmakers just hours after the texas
shooting just days after a shooter
walked into a grocery store
to gun down african-american
patrons we have another sandy hook on
our hands the mass shooting at sandy
hook elementary school 10 years ago this
december was in murphy's district we
probably haven't learned bill daley is a
former fbi investigator we spoke to him
tuesday evening still early in the texas
investigation i'm sorry to say that you
know the sandy hook incident uh
as much as this may may turn out to
parallel it in some some cases um it may
have some differences but the bottom
line is is that
you know a and a trudeau was able to get
into a
a primary school uh and murder young
children uh we do know in sandy hook
that the individual was actually let in
because his mother had worked in the
school and he was known to people in the
school and as much as they had security
at the door he was able to kind of talk
his way in in this case we're not too
sure what the security arrangements were
but again an individual burst into a
elementary school and killed these young
treasures of ours
where they sat
so i think what we've probably have not
learned is how to reinforce security
around
our schools in this case our primary
schools or more junior schools
over the years focus has been more on
the uh high schools and colleges uh
where incidents of the past have taken
place where students have come in
themselves with weapons and committed
these these atrocities
yeah i mean we have
been making an effort to harden schools
to make schools harder targets as you
say sometimes it's more at the high
school level
so you think we should be
doing more of that in more places how do
we do that
i do that we need to be doing it more
places we you know certainly we we're
looking for trip wires that are out
there in the community uh for
individuals who may pose a risk to
uh to any groups of people whether it
happened to be a you know a religious
group or another social group or an
ethnic group or a school however we
can't be protecting uh all the time from
these uh these creatures that can loom
from the swamp and commit these
horrendous acts so i think what we need
to be looking at is hardening the the
school perimeters
and i think it's it's it's time that we
focus uh that attention on being both
kind of physical as well as the the
school security officer programs that
have been successful in other other
places and other levels of education and
look to employ those in the primary
school level in the in the more junior
school level
how do we find a balance i mean
is it time for metal detectors at every
school should schools be like
courthouses
well i think every situation is going to
be different so i think in some
instances you know i've worked on some
programs in the inner cities where they
use metal detectors
and they have been doing that for a long
time in major cities like new york city
um whoever in more junior or
or lower level
schools or the primary schools um you
know probably not expecting at that
point for children to be carrying
weapons this may be more so the threat
from outside so each one of these
programs needs to be adjusted for
uh the kind of the the nuances of the
age group we're dealing with the
physical circumstances around
the building the community you're in but
i think the focus does need to be around
both hardening targets uh education of
both faculty and students as to what to
do when an incident does if it was to
occur
uh but all those measures to really kind
of prevent
things from entering into that secure
area
in fact someone mentioned something on
one of the talk programs about using
some of the coveted money which i
thought was a great idea some of the
unspent coveted money
that's been already been released by the
government
to provide you know school safety uh
around covid and apply it more towards
these i'd say more kind of pragmatic
elements around you know around school
security that we've just been speaking
about
the texas school shooting happened less
than three weeks after the mass shooting
at a supermarket in buffalo new york
that's a suspected hate crime targeting
black shoppers and workers
how do we prevent crime
when it's driven by racism or by mental
illness i mean that seems to be a
tougher question
yeah that is a type of question it's a
it's a very broad question obviously
because it does cover everything from
people who are just uh
emotionally deranged people filled with
evil uh people who have various levels
of psycho psychiatric uh issues
affecting him
um i mean we speak about those programs
let's say away from the locations where
the incidents take place where there
happens to be in buffalo in the
supermarket or in the texas incident
school and we looked at the broader
community
there are quite a number of states that
have the red flag laws which do allow
people from law enforcement or local
government agencies as well as health
professionals
to intercede and to make sure somebody
is flagged to prevent them from getting
a weapon
so there are some measures in place
however we found out there in the
community the broader community is that
there's been some reluctance i i feel uh
both from
family members who may see somebody
acting in an emotionally or
psychologically uh deranged way i feel
maybe they can handle it themselves they
don't want that person to be stigmatized
they don't want all the authorities in
but we do need to make sure that people
who are in such things as the mental
health facilities are aware that they
can you know take these acts and not
permanently but temporarily keep this
person away from any weapon that may
cause them or others harm as crime rates
in general have been rising around the
country bail reform has been getting
some of the blame especially when it
comes to repeat offenders the gunman
accused of killing a man on a new york
city subway train who surrendered to
police on tuesday had been arrested many
times before on charges including felony
assault and attempted murder with a
still open gun charge from two years ago
the violence on the q train last sunday
morning was committed by another repeat
offender who was given every leeway by
the criminal justice system
we cannot and will not stand for it nypd
commissioner keshan sewell calling again
for judges in new york state to be able
to consider the level of danger in bail
decisions some argue fewer prosecutions
may also be fueling crime and what about
the internet where twisted ideologies
can spread quickly you know i personally
do think that it does affect uh
individuals have a propensity for for
committing these uh these horrendous
acts you know whether it's something
immediate or whether it's something that
is in the back of their mind as they are
going through some disjointed uh efforts
to carry out some evil plots that they
have against either groups of
individuals
or
at religious locations or at schools so
i do think that it does sit in the back
their mind i mean it's it's certainly a
difficult balance between uh the media
covering these incidents from a news
perspective and to keep everyone
informed which is their their obligation
as a news gathering reporting
organization
and and those who may look to kind of uh
amplify that or
or speak about it in some ways that in
in some some cases may actually give
these these future perpetrators kind of
a sense of
of uh kind of engender a sense of
emotional kind of a thrill out of it and
and gather their uh kind of feelings
that they may get some garner some
uh magic attention to themselves even if
it is uh you know post their their their
passing so i do think that it does play
a role where that balance is um i don't
really know
a tragedy like this texas school
shooting inevitably does reignite the
debate about
gun laws
what do you think could actually change
anything in terms of preventing violence
or even getting different sides
of the gun debate on the same page
yeah it's always a very a very sensitive
issue and certainly one like to myself i
mean i certainly supported and uh been
fully behind this our second amendment
we don't know yet what uh the incident
texas may reveal with regard to
the weapons that were used how they were
gained whether illegally illegally uh
this person came into possession of them
but i do think as people who are leaders
on gun advocacy aside you know do need
to address this concern from an
emotional standpoint and realize that
it's out there that it is something that
people are most concerned about
we look at most of the shootings that
take place in in our inner cities
uh where these sensors take place you
know many times these weapons are not
ones that are uh you know that come
through you know legal channels uh
they're ill-gotten illegally gotten uh
people shouldn't have them to begin with
whether they you know are mentally
competent or not it doesn't matter they
just shouldn't have them
president biden is expected to mark two
years since the death of george floyd in
minneapolis
with an executive order that amounts to
police reform because
other proposals had stalled in congress
he's expected among other things to
require
that federal law enforcement review
use of force policies and revise them
are you concerned that this could run
the risk of putting too many limits on
law enforcement or is this something
that's needed in terms of restoring
trust in law enforcement in certain
communities
to help get a better handle on crime
well i actually think that any further
encumbrance on law enforcement from
doing their jobs is furthering the
situation we just talked about with
increased you know crime rates certainly
obviously from my background i'm a full
supporter of law enforcement i realized
that once in a while you may come across
you know a bad egg and apple out there
who who commit acts they shouldn't
but i was saying for the most part is
that you know our law enforcement
agencies you know
have policies procedures uh they have
things in place that i think are are
reasonable for the most part i don't
think that kind of a wholesale kind of
review of programs or trying to limit
what's already out there that would
prevent police from doing their jobs is
is a good thing by far
i think even the suggestion that they
they have programs out there that are in
any way
potentially um pose a risk to the
population i i think even that
suggestion starts to again demean some
of the police and their their position
uh and their ability to carry out their
acts i mean there have been some limits
as as you know as a result of
the george floyd uh incident uh where
you know police are very concerned about
uh wrestling people to the ground and
using for you know physical force
because it may be something that they
feel as though they themselves
personally going to be liable for um as
opposed to being covered by their acts
as the police officer and perhaps the
police department and the
and the local government backing them so
i think it's a very very
sensitive area i think it's one that
needs to be looked at very carefully
again i don't think a
a wholesale kind of review of these
programs is good or the suggestion that
what's already out there that police
have is ill-conceived or again presents
a risk to the public i think that does a
kind of injustice both to the population
and to the police who are trying to
protect them
former fbi investigator bill daley
thanks so much for your time
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this is guy benson with your fox news
commentary coming up
another surge of migrants republicans
warn is coming is on hold for now with a
federal judge blocking the biden
administration from ending title 42 a
trump-era border policy that prevented
migrants from entering the u.s out of
covid concern homeland security
secretary alejandra mayorkas also
expects that surge when the policies
eventually lifted and says they'll be
ready for it but
we will not implement policies of
cruelty
that disregard our asylum laws even with
title 42 in place border patrol stopped
nearly 235 000 migrants coming here
illegally in april the most in a month
in over 20 years and many were allowed
into the u.s
texas is one of the states that's sued
to keep title 42 in place gop governor
greg abbott tells fox when president
trump was enforcing tele-42 people were
not coming over the border this is a
problem that starts at the top with
president biden knowingly purposefully
allowing people to come in knowingly
violating the law fox correspondent bill
malugen is that a front row seat to the
surge nothing has changed since that
federal ruling all it did is it kept the
status quo in place we caught up with
bill near the border in eagle pass texas
in the immediate hours after that
federal ruling we saw large groups of
illegal immigrants crossing in the eagle
pass
openly broad daylight wading across the
rio grande waving to our drone as it was
watching them over ahead groups of 150
120 60.
the illegal crossings did not slow down
and they're not going to slow down is it
just that border patrol agents are
overwhelmed they just can't get
everybody
well yeah that's part of the problem is
you have these big massive groups coming
over to turn themselves in hundreds in
size and that requires a large border
patrol response they have to get agents
out there to process them and do the
paperwork and transport and when that
happens agents are pulled off patrol
elsewhere they just don't have the
manpower to handle it so there are parts
of the border that go unpatrolled when
these big groups come across and the
cartels know that so what they do is
they send a couple hundred people over
at once knowing that border patrol is
going to have to respond with a lot of
their resources it'll suck up their
resources and then elsewhere where the
border opens up and there's no patrol
they will send drugs criminals and their
high value clientele all right so the
ones who are going to go into custody
they're not worried about going to
border patrol custody because
it seems like looking at the numbers a
lot of them are going to be allowed into
the us illegally anyway
yeah no a lot of them when we when they
come over they're smiling they're giving
us thumbs up they're winking you know
fist bumping because they know uh
there's a very good chance they're going
to be released into the united states
just in april alone
dhs released 118 000 migrants into the
country they only removed 113 000 so
this is the first time that i can
remember that more people were released
after crossing illegally than were
removed so
they know if they get here they will
very likely be released into the united
states now most of those who are not
allowed in
were not allowed in under the title 42
policy with the coveted concern i think
it saw 98 thousand of the 113 000 it was
because of title 42. the concern is when
we lift that most of them would be
allowed in is that the deal is that what
would happen
once title 42 drops which will happen
someday you can expect a big chunk of
those expulsions to then flip to
releases because border patrol holding
facilities do not have the capacity to
handle such an influx and they will have
to be doing
mass releases so yes you'll see a big
inverse flip instead of expulsions they
will turn to releases the biden
administration has been saying that most
single males coming across the border
are not allowed in would that still be
the case if they lift title 42 do you
know
it used to be the case but that stopped
being the case for a while i mean we
have seen especially down in brownsville
mass releases of hundreds of single
adult men from federal custody uh every
single day you know every single day
almost they do title 42
single adults from certain countries but
it's it's hit or miss like venezuela
cuba colombia nicaragua none of them are
title 42 mexicans are title 42 haitians
are title 42 it all it just kind of
depends on what country they're coming
from but we have started seeing large
large large numbers of single adult
single adult men being mass released
from federal custody we started seeing
that back in january so what is it about
the countries like cuba or venezuela
they don't accept them back is that why
that's correct okay
in some cases mexico won't let us
expel them back into mexico they won't
take them back
so it again it all just kind of depends
on which country is which so when mexico
won't take them back in their home
country won't take them back we have to
release them here into the u.s all right
now when it comes to
another policy there was the remain in
mexico policy that was under president
trump the biden administration
grudgingly uh has that in place
is that being enforced where they have
to wait in mexico some of these asylum
seekers for their hearings
it's really not it's being enforced in
such small numbers you know couple a
couple hundred people here and there
when you have 234 000 people crossing
the border it's less than a drop in the
bucket it is not having any meaningful
impact on the border here all right the
way they are enforcing it
throughout this months-long migrant
surge republicans have worried about
terror suspects slipping into the
country last month congressman jim
jordan got into it with alejandro
mayorkas the secretary of homeland
security does not know the answer to the
status of 42 individuals who came to our
southern border illegally are on the
no-fly list and then and the no and the
terrorist watch list you do not do not
know whether they have been released or
not into the country that's your
testimony ranking member jordan as i've
said before i will provide you the data
now there are new questions after a
suspected terrorist from colombia was
allowed into the country illegally last
month his name is esnardo garcia amado
on april 18th he was released by border
patrol into the u.s near yuma arizona
after he crossed illegally they let him
go and ice gave him a gps monitoring
device three days after they release him
the fbi identifies him as a suspected
terrorist on the terror watch list they
let ice know in the miami area because
he had since moved to florida
for some reason it then took
two weeks after that id
for ice to get approval to go rearrest
him in the state of florida it took two
weeks for them to go get him they did
end up re-arresting him in pinellas
county near the tampa bay area
and he is back in ice custody now but uh
what appears to have happened is they
released him without waiting for a
federal check to come back on his
background and then they found out he
was a hit on the terror watch list
several days after he was released and
there's been no explanation as to why it
took two weeks to go get them i i
reached out to dhs and i asked how did
this happen why did this happen why did
it take so long to go get them all they
would say essentially in a comment is
once they learned derogatory information
about this individual
they went out and promptly arrested him
and i think a lot of people would have
questions about two weeks being prompted
sure florida's governor ron desantis a
republican of course who's been very
critical of biden policy at the borders
one of those who wants answers
the question also is
when they take someone across and
they're processing these people they
don't check through all these screening
centers first before putting a say a
monitor on them and sending them off
sounds like it's hit or miss former ice
director tom homan said that yeah he's
been in touch with border patrol agents
who you know the administration has
placed such an emphasis on process
process process as fast as you can so we
avoid images of overcrowding that in
some cases that yes they are releasing
people before their checks come back so
that is obviously incredibly concerning
and that appears to be what potentially
happened here in this incident all right
now are migrants still being put on
buses like in brownsville i know we've
talked about that in the past and
getting on and going and being taken to
other parts of texas other parts of the
u.s flown places
yes that happens every single day all
along the border non-stop the hundreds
are released to ngos every day they then
get put on buses they get taken other
cities they get dropped off at airports
that happens every day and it has
happened every day for as long as i can
remember during this border crisis and
the people who are taken to these other
places across america
they just have what a notice that they
have to appear at some point in court
someday
some of them have what's called an nta a
notice to appear meaning they do have to
you know go to a court date usually
years in the future
others are just simply paroled when
they're paroled it means they have no
immigration charge no court date they
are free to go they can even they're
even eligible to apply for work permits
um and they
the government paroled over 90 000
people in april
so it just it just sort of depends on on
the person in their case
so uh now as we await title 42 and the
potential for
more coming across do you know are
people waiting across the border for
this to happen
yes we've gone over to mexican cities
nuevo-laredo piedras negras and we've
talked to migrants over there who told
us that yes they are waiting their
initial plan was on may 23rd they were
going to cross over when it was supposed
to drop yesterday that didn't happen so
they're still over there waiting
actually down in the mexican city of
reynosa across from mcallen down in the
rio grande valley there are camps set up
with thousands of migrants who are
waiting to cross 10 cities essentially
set up over there so uh what they decide
to do remains to be seen in recent days
but i would not be surprised if they
decide to just cross anyways are there
are they a lot of them haitians i mean
you mentioned that under title 42
you can be sent back for instance to
haiti would that mean that the haitians
are waiting
there there were well over a thousand
haitians waiting in nuevo laredo they
have since moved we don't know where
they went to but yes all along the
border there are large numbers of
haitians who are crossing in multiple
different sectors typically it's been up
here in the del rio sector
there are some down in the rio grande
valley but yes there are haitians
on the mexican side who are waiting to
cross this time of year we're getting
into the summer where it's going to be
i'm sure it's very hot where you are now
already and it's you know
are you
seeing or is there concern
migrants coming in that kind of weather
it gets incredibly hot it was the the
highest numbers we saw last year were in
the middle of summer in august and july
uh and yeah my i mean migrants have been
dying in the open desert when we visited
the big bend sector just last week we
came across the corpse of a 28 year old
honduran woman in the open desert who
died
in the element so that is absolutely a
concern but when the temperatures heat
up just like what we saw last year the
activity heats up as well so we are
anticipating we're going into the the
highest activity months right now and we
expect to see
big big numbers going into the summer
and you you still go down there are you
still going down every couple weeks a
month to witness all this yes sir i am
yeah every every couple weeks going down
i think i've spent more than 200 days in
texas since may of last year and so is
it different at all now versus when you
first started going or has it been the
same constantly through the 200 days
you've been there
it's worse this it's worse this year
than it was last year the numbers are
significantly up compared to last year
and last year set the all-time record so
when fiscal year 2022 is done we could
be pushing upwards of well over 2
million illegal crossings at our
southern border and that does not even
account for the gotaways there are more
got aways this year than there were last
year
so it it the situation seems
significantly worse this year
bill malugen fox news national
correspondent who's been spending a lot
of time in texas joining us from eagle
pass thanks very much for being here
thanks for having me
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
guy benson benson
what's on your mind on monday the
central intelligence agency put out a
press release announcing that two stars
had been added to its memorial wall
which is located at the agency's
headquarters in langley virginia the
wall commemorates officers at the cia
who've given their lives in service and
as of this week two more of those
anonymous commemorations were chiseled
into that wall the total now stands at
139 stars we don't know who these people
are we don't know if they were male or
female what their skin color was what
their background was we don't know how
they died what they were doing where
they were serving all we know is that
they paid the ultimate sacrifice
pursuing a mission to keep the american
people and the american homeland safe
from foreign threats they knew they
would never get glory even in death
their work and their sacrifice would not
make them household names no matter how
heroic their exploits to those
represented on that memorial we say rest
in peace and thank you from a grateful
nation i'm guy benson
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast former federal prosecutor and
four-term u.s congressman from south
carolina brings you a one-of-a-kind
podcast subscribe and listen now by
going to foxnewspodcasts.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes